like when we did that dumb megan mccain
thing we were like should we even put
this our like the funniest in just
insane irreverent yeah so we just do
[ __ ] now you know what yeah you know
it's owned by NBC yeah well you know
that megan mccain [ __ ] her dad is owned
by CBS from your teaming on accent yeah
yet serious yeah yeah classic one yeah
it's a fait it's offensive yeah oh yeah
but i appreciate it yeah when you hear i
always said i hope you understand what
Long Island culture is know which isn't
work that so long on is basically the
suburb in a lot of ways of Manhattan of
New York I mean it yeah the island and
it goes way way up bring it up on the
mat nice but it's provincial you don't
it's 118 miles long in Hatton is eight
months yeah so Long Island is a hundred
nation horses it's quite a horse yeah
it's nice there's parts of it of
beautiful well that's where the Hamptons
is yeah I didn't idea that's where yeah
I don't let Han top it they Hamptons
that's for the Kennedys you still there
more of these vineyard but there but
there's there's a good club there on
Long Island to right Bob go to brokerage
which Louis loves yeah worked out a
special yeah but but it's an aggressive
yeah the world very loud that address
all its aggressive oh it's probably the
best word for aggressive you can get
punched in the face they're probably
easier I'll make a call there were a lot
of mobsters live - yeah yeah yeah it's
it's also just it's just Italian Irish
Jewish New York that goes way back and
yeah you can so easily
you might yeah again they're probably a
couple places you can get any punch
device maybe Dagestan but probably not
right New York for sure Mona
Laura I'm more I've never been at
Dagestan but I feel like the people
there much better their problem
it's it's it's a no-nonsense part of the
world but it's great and a lot of
greatness and and it's like well you
know what the thing about it is it's
funny right so it's just it's ridiculous
that bagel guys from Long Island not
arrested that little guy that flipped
out I did yelling yeah
I mean that's kinda I wouldn't claim it
here's the thing everybody was shocked
it wasn't from Long Island you see that
three times a day on Long Island it's
either a woman a fat woman who's mad or
a guy like that like somebody's always
flipping out in a bagel store or in a
diner and you were born and raised it
yeah born and raised both of which are
part of the Jewish and Irish culture
yeah an Italian it's an Irish a Jewish
and Italian the hours will be quiet and
punch in the face
yeah Italians will freak out and be very
loud the Jews same thing Yeah right it's
yes for demanding people yeah and that's
Long Island you choose you have Italians
you have your african-american Irish
people I'm Puerto Rican
when I go on auditions I'm like I am
yeah but long it's a fun it's a fun spot
you know it's good you started stand-up
there they would love you there I'm
shocked you have not done I've never
done that I know I have I have friends
that live there who love you I need to
go and I've told me like you should get
on the fighter in the kit this is Long
Island lots of those yeah those people I
need a lot of cops who shouldn't be cops
it's a big white Otteson a lot of cops
you probably shouldn't be cops yeah like
that are huge fans of you I love that
people friends of mine that have been
given guns around my home like well one
day it's gonna be you know Artie Lange
has a friend he used to come and visit
us who was essentially a bad cop not a
bad guy but a bad cop good he'd be like
you shakedown drug dealers yeah and kind
of talk about it yeah I even let girls
go it'd be like you know look I Drive
drunk so I don't want to be a hypocrite
but you can kiss your job goodbye how to
live again and then you know then they'd
be like you know you're cute he'd be
like we're kind of cute MIT it basically
that you know the girl thought he was
cute yeah I was on he's like you know
what fine I got my back of my patrol car
we don't this is not all bad buddy not a
bunny badge but is that what the car
badge buddy's bad yeah you do your first
set was in Long Island first set was in
Long Island in a tattoo parlor coffee
shop Hellion
a tattoo parlor you heard that when you
were bombing he would hear and of course
so long I had tattoos so guys getting
like Cadillac
you know his girlfriend's name pad it
over with like the Twin Towers you know
something like that
Long Island dad to parlor so you know
you can only imagine the people getting
tattooed would be like bro that sucks
yeah like bro not good and I'm gonna be
like hey by the way yeah
Broward the one yeah and said bro yes
descent said that way more than any
other word yeah Allen 100% no brah
bro bro yeah everybody's row yeah yeah
bro I'm sold
yeah you and I would you would be I feel
like oh yeah you would love yeah I have
so many friends in a personal trainer
deejays and they just sell HGH and an
Applebee's parking lot that's what that
boils when you go to the beach correct
me if I'm wrong
come on the the amount of just shoes
heads lights on the beach so aggressive
yeah yeah your ass kicked in the surf
again you'd be fine guys like me not so
much
not I got by but just being funny so you
always need a funny guy yeah to make fun
of what just happened as to your friends
getting put in a patrol story tell yeah
yeah you need a story time with a guy
from 300 the eye patch yeah gotta break
it all down you know but yeah it was a
it was a fun place to grow up the food
is sick yeah that's why I have you know
hold on you girls are sacred in that
language means it's really good yes good
it's good sick hey man yeah what kind of
food I'm talking Italian for bacon egg
and cheese sandwiches big bureaus as big
clams all kinds of shellfish
buffalo calamari like I'm not monster
[ __ ] yeah that's why you don't know
that's why I'm key don't ask you don't
know you know yeah I'm a professional
fighter now have you a question
I've watched a woman in the face yeah a
man messing with women darn your the
honestly
yeah no I'm pumped I feel kind of better
I have to change I have to can't you
know everybody's gonna die I mean
everybody I know is gonna die
yeah have you always had like have you
been like a bigger I started being a
bigger dude after high school I was
actually not I just follow me on
Instagram when I was a senior of high
school I was like much it was much
better that is that on your profile it's
not my Instagram yeah you can see see
what I was now you might be like okay
it's still too big but it's really not I
am a big bill my mother is big my dad's
not that big
my mother's a big Long Island woman
there you go right there to the left in
the suit oh I saw you post in Catholic
school yes sir that's not there's not a
[ __ ] I'm Brian yeah yeah so I got to
get back to that yeah it's just gonna be
you know Renan Brennan is always dieting
yeah well I text him so like it was a
smoothie the other day I'm like what's
this he's like and I'm like yeah you
know he actually even though I don't
even know if you've read any books but
being an athlete he really does know
[Music]
well you'll be super specific we'll try
to preach it ro gonna be like give up
sugar and grain yeah and I'm like okay
okay okay but specific what can I just
tell you he'll but sugar in car yeah he
even knows like supplements and [ __ ]
yeah well that's what I saw I went to
Vitamin Shoppe last night I want there
to Vitamin Shoppe and Vitamin Shoppe has
these little Kido like why give me a
look there it says keto on it I know
and it says little peanut butter cups
little keto cookies little keto bar
cookie dough things was I wrong why you
give me a look it says here only three
days in I understand it but it's like my
Titan shop it's called the Vitamix
potion is it bad I thought a lot a lot
of you had like like it's like alcohol
sugars but a lot of that like sugar
alcohol now that's in it it's the
problem really [ __ ] in your pants or but
also ever talk you're very but also your
body might go oh sweet you know
an insulin level I got to be honest with
you I did eat it and I did like start to
be like ooh you know I felt like kind of
like but you're only three days in you
shouldn't need that stuff yet dude look
here's the thing
I know that I shouldn't you just wanted
I just approval I want your person yeah
you're not doing anything so I've had no
bread Ivan no rice no pasta no grains no
today we're eating all the cookies and
the brothers you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm sticking with it I'm sticking
with it till I at least lose 20 or 30
pounds they're not that I will get rid
of it and put it right back onto the
weekend yeah that's my sword dad I'm
like yo I want at least 30 pounds like
yeah how long is this gonna stay I'd
like you to meet kita for life yeah get
down to this way well it's very tough
because you look how disciplined certain
people are and and they they cook a lot
yeah and it's very tough they're not
cooking a lot to really follow any
kiddos pretty easy if you don't cook
okay right so yesterday I worked out
with him at this yeah class yeah she
come to this hot spring class with me he
goes every day so I walk in I had no
idea what to expect I walk in it's a it
sounds like a giant fart in there you
have the heat blasting this is in the
valley it's called the sweat shop yeah
it's so hot I can't see it's in the it's
in the dark would like some strobe
lights Legionnaires disease there we are
and I I get in and I always sees the
light shine through Bert's here and he's
kind of losing this hair psych yeah like
right that's Bert so I sit down next to
him and we're going and like my eyes
adjust to the dark and like I like your
bread I go dude where's all the chicks
at yeah cuz why don't you where's all
the chicks Etios not here bro and then
it's just him home by an hour an hour Oh
an hour us doing work but but to the
point Bert does he's been super strict
cuz he's getting ready for silver
October so he's doing intermittent
fasting he's working out every single
day and then he's like the only this
bunny goes you know I'm kind of losing
weight man thinking you know doing some
stuff on get shred and
you'd be cool man they'll be really cool
and then he goes the only problem is
wanting to stand up might have a few
drinks and the [ __ ] Gila monster
comes out and I just [ __ ] right that's
all of us yeah you a momzilla monster
what is intermittent fasting so you only
eat not like in an hour period during
the day so we have eight hours to eat
whatever you need to do outside that you
don't touch so now let me ask you a
question so for eight hours I'm allowed
to eat anything that's what you guys
what he just said no wait I need six
pies yeah but what you can do you
there's a new thing called 36:12
we go 36 hours just water and coffee
which I get you through those three six
hours okay I have 12 hours eat when
everyone become a drug addict for three
days Stacey goes wandering around hours
yeah yeah I love that guy that's what it
is you don't eat you just it's just
caffeine and you lie on your floor and
Twitter some people do yeah and then
what and then at the end of that what do
you do then for those 12 hours you go
bonkers and then another third that
seems like a healthy life yeah I see my
saying you can sustain fasting from you
know religion people who were in a
minute fasting they've realized that
when they did it after a while that
their body was responded by their brains
every religion I think of Raving every
major religion I can think of has a time
of fasting I mean Islam you so fast for
a month so they could ride me can run to
Islam in order to lose weight you should
see I was my father when I can see he's
like I'm so proud you look so much
better quick thing gone Muslim I show up
with a goofy Mike listen I want to go on
naked and afraid just to lose weight and
what yeah
where's 30 days you just kill what you
eat the bugs your butt naked but I just
30 days your you worry about what your
weight but no I'm fine yeah I mean I'm
not yeah you're a big muscular guy yeah
you've never really been fat dude no
never get out I mean you're just up to
73 too big for me even that I mean it
kind of goes all over your body
yeah but still have you don't you feel
maybe you don't feel the same but do you
feel good Timothy I guess I don't
I like something like it it depends I I
look at other people I go they must feel
better you know what I mean you're
stress eater that's what I I think I eat
like I don't eat a lot of [ __ ] I don't
need a lot of fast food I don't I don't
drink soda I don't eat chips I don't do
any of that stuff okay I like good food
now they couldn't act a nice restaurant
and unfortunately you know sometimes you
have a chocolate souffle or you have
like something you shouldn't have you
you eat you know a bowl of pasta let me
this ludus up one of the joys of lino
but there should be other choice so
that's the yeah but [ __ ] eating late
that's a huge problem for economics s
the biggest fun drinking late and eating
late laughter all the way she always man
you were in high school and then was
there an event or some that forced you
to like gain weight no just over time
life life happened and then you just
start eating and eating and eating and
then you just you know you wake up one
morning you're 300 pounds yeah what
happened yeah so but that's why now I'm
going to I'm going the other way I'm
gonna scale it down you do the Jonah
Hill I'm gonna do the Jonah Hill yeah
did you see Jonah Hill he got fat again
he goes like this because he can't get
movie roles thin that's a reality
no one likes something no one really
likes him I know it's better for his
health I'm selfish right people find out
that they just know more vulnerable to
money I mean let me see that let me see
the difference I got to be I he looks
like a Hari Krishna when he's thin and
he shaves his head like he looks like a
dude you don't want to talk too good he
looks like an [ __ ] he's thin he like
super friendly when he's fat yeah like
he looks like a vegan blogger when he's
thin like he becomes he looks good when
he's thin though let me see that picture
with him and a tank top
okay that's better good-looking kid
there it's better he's a good-looking
kid
I love the agent like his agent having
to call me girl listen Jonah we think
you look great but the reality is you
need to gain eighty pounds yeah like
dude where's
they problem is all the roads like
here's the thing you do how do you feel
good that's vent out he goes into his
agents always have a huge cake like
listen one of the producers out we're
here is salaburu celebrating we're
celebrating you just got an offer but
we'd like you to really just kind of
enjoy yourself a little why well because
I can't say gain weight yeah they can't
say lose weight
you know go out and really just start
you know let your hair down yeah yeah
yeah have a shaved head yeah I don't
were saying you know we mean we're not
the old Jonah was he yeah I learned what
Hollywood is about when already language
on the on MADtv and had little means
public knowledge had a little how old
yeah that little to prompt draw geisha
to faintest noses done love him love him
so much but he a little issue and he got
skinny yeah and he one of the producers
I'm calling our manager I have the same
manager and said look man like this is
kind of awkward but we need a heavy guy
on the show god what am I in there you
know he's he's skinny and so we in my
poor manager didn't poor managers trying
to save his job he goes I'll get him fat
I figured house get him back to normal
in other words get him off the drugs but
yeah but it was it's sometimes it's like
we need you that way well I did that
with Christy Ali Ryan it was this big
show and everybody was talking about it
I mean it was everybody was talking
about it and then um she got skinny and
the show got kids but but in that case
Michael fat actress correct so it's like
if rebel Wilson loses a ton of weight
you're like what the [ __ ] Ryan like
whether one of the quality she has it's
like you know yeah is she now it's like
now cuz the fat active is like the fat
duo you watch them do we're tired you
watch the MTV Awards
yeah it was like a LG qtb fat what was
also like now if you now if you go out
in certain rooms and you're like hey I
just lost 50 pounds
the audience would used to applaud now
there's no they just look at you like
okay well you should have loved yourself
you know they want they want that's
horseshit
it's horrible like oh what's the name
Liz oh yeah Amy Schumer did that movie
about being troubling people like she's
not fat enough she should she can walk
on her own that's not representation she
doesn't need a machine to sleep her
sister yes she can we want to [ __ ] sits
on a scooter yeah we want I mean
literally they got that Liz owes then
she's like in a bikini she's very
this is she's very talented she's great
she's danced in front of a big-ass a
giant like a basketball beside this
[ __ ] sebastian has to go
hey there's cannolis in the back for
everybody Liz oh yeah it's just not
right like he said I wish he had turned
on that audience it started roasting me
- no she went full by Wilbur
Philadelphia sound oh are you and you're
a strong man - man no you're gay yeah
come out yes good hard
cheers Cabella what a [ __ ] name is
non-stop no you suck absolutely like
this was the whole Awards was like
celebrating fat [ __ ] yeah gay people
it was so strange
how's the MT viewer yeah yes Sebastian
was the host so I didn't see going to a
time for fat enter tots in right now
that is Hugh here on the wrong end of
that is huge right now Andy Ruiz is the
[ __ ] heavyweight champion in the
world I'm yeah it's bad big boys it's
all about big people okay well those
awards were strange man they were are
but everybody like we're also older
they're like died everybody hears Miley
Cyrus so if they just went through a
divorce yesterday right and she was
through divorce she's 20 to 23 were
together yeah eight weeks
yeah but she's saying it was the best
performance that [ __ ] that we all get
older right maybe that's why we can all
dude man it's not for axis isn't it -
new organism rights also I don't buy it
I just don't buy it but I thought like
no nobody know but first of all Miley
Cyrus his new video has people in
wheelchairs like dancing around and all
this stuff
I mean rolling around you know yeah oh
yeah her new video which one the slide
the mother's daughter
oh I've seen eyes you know her new hits
the jail it's it's not it's not a bad
song but like it's also like why what
Dean you care about that last year like
if you care so much now yeah they've
wait a minute I mean Hollywood's fake oh
so hold on you saw people in wheelchairs
like last year right they were still
there yeah we're yet now yeah you know
gender reassignment surgery that's kind
of a sexy pic shot of her right there
and that the slide of her new jam and I
don't even know like she just licks
herself and licks the floor I think she
does something going on yeah I don't
think it's generally I don't think I was
that very ladylike
woman power she like made she wants to
destroy the Disney Channel just
conventional morality trying to do yeah
they're all just trying Hillard adoption
went the Eilish is like bleeding from
her eye she's having like satanic
ceremonies on stage and she were these
young girls like oh this is awesome
clearly like an MK ULTRA victim if the
night she has horrible depression yeah
and she refuses to wear like you have no
idea what her body looks like she's in
baggy clothes yeah Billy Alice yeah she
said she doesn't want to get she's gonna
be known for like yeah whatever sensual
want to be sexualized yet she sings
about sleeping with people's dads I got
in trouble cuz I said she looked like
somebody Harvey wants he put in the cage
for ten years and I got in trouble for
that an Instagram took my thing down
really
yes they did looks like everyone's
intolerant gates for ten years and just
left her with [ __ ] high that's what
it is I mean there's something wrong in
any of her videos I mean look at that go
over to the left right there where she's
bleeding blue blood out of a rock like
cries for help
right yeah she's also ten so take
anything she says here is that music is
like this she's like huh but I mean it's
chance yeah it's not good yeah she's
good she's got angst man she's got angst
and she's doing good she's price of it
she's killing it man she's [ __ ]
killing it she's got a big on Soundcloud
Brian take a hike because you're 60 I'm
say anyways are we talking about there
oh yes she's 16 she's a big on South my
brother would produce her music yeah now
she's like the number one artist in the
world good for her she's talented
obviously right I mean whatever
I mean is she is is it I mean she
dresses we don't know we don't know she
yasss used dresses different over it
she's gonna be talented too if a bunch
of senators put me in a circle and lit
me on fire and you know branded me it's
pretty and then tossed the whole [ __ ]
this is a premium stuff right and you're
like they're all a Taylor Swift saw in
this cult in that you know the
Illuminati blah blah blah and I'm like
oh that's all bs and then I see her in
like the middle of a circle of candles
and I'm like oh maybe there is a problem
maybe something's wrong she's been
unleashed
yeah she's been groomed release a desert
there
she might be a little picky right they
all have a gate god we've never seen her
be in 19 and feels pretty heavy
seventeen seventeen to be fair she's
been doing it since she was like 13 yes
yeah since 13 so 17 and she's probably
god bless her listen I'm open to collab
with it everything I said was really
insecurity yeah fear I'll sacrifice
animals with you I'll do it whatever you
want to do hon I'll come without blood
what the [ __ ] I'm on keto I gotta start
wearing big blood Tito you can eat you
can eat there you can drink blood of the
yeah you can drink coke she like a new
age a virile Levine remember her oh yeah
she's boy that she likes
Avril Lavigne I think is ever Olivia no
longer a hit she's just kind of I mean I
really that's a medical issue as case
she died room was probably in a Ralph's
right now shooting heroin you know
things haven't worked out yeah she got
super sick with wine fame no reality
yeah there was this disease called
people moving on he caught it it was
fatal yeah oh that's sad I always get
paranoid I'm gonna get bit by a tick
could probably be the best thing that
happened oh she got [ __ ] out Lyme
disease everybody has Lyme disease they
say oh it's it's it's my lime and then
Rogan had an infectious disease guy he
was like we don't think so she got
really sick though she got really sick
yeah yeah it's just people that have
been you know taking drugs for the last
three yeah I was gonna say sometimes you
just live a shitty she's just not
healthy at all yes she's coming off the
heroin yeah yeah you've been out
psyching the how about I psyching this
morning the guy goes hey bro
he has headphones on and you can tell
you hikes every day goes bro huge
Ralph's snake up there be careful but
didn't tell me where it ruined the
[ __ ] hike man I was so scared the
rest of the time now what is white but
where did it pointed in a general area
well I'm on a map pointing in general
like this there hiking's when you you
throw on a pair of shorts and some some
durable boot
how where bandana sure ever go shirtless
Camelbak shirt yeah and I just I just uh
I step it up a mountain coming if I want
to come one day you see you walk up the
mountain yeah or he can run jog
well let's we'll walk let's realize we
poached small animals great yeah
interesting some rattlesnakes a little
dangers involved a lot of white people
have never done a hike I went to
Griffith Park once do you remember this
movie remember this movie I'm gonna do
I'm gonna quote it he was especially
hard on little things rise bottom
motorcycling just below as a [ __ ]
bunny rabbit away with a huge guy what
was that and the younger movie will know
the guy who played the part was that
what fought Larry Holmes for the title
Raising Arizona oh that's a great movie
but I didn't I didn't it's a great movie
that's so old you guys yeah no I mean
it's a good I remember the in
blockbuster there was like an empty pool
right and they were on lounge chairs in
front of it yes I remember seeing the
Cossack on rosemary it's one of the
great moves Nic Cage is one of the great
I want to watch I got to start watch
Cobb is really use a thing Brendan if
you start watching some of the older
movies dude they're so good oh that's
why I literally or some of them we've
seen them but it's also like in music
like the 80s and 70s music holds up like
that's gonna hold us not gonna jam to
some [ __ ] queen or something oh yeah
yeah see every corner ational yeah yeah
understand but then it's like is this
Billy Eilish song you know hold on well
al Berlin so I had a guy who's that
who's did a podcast with him he's he's
written all the Backstreet Boys songs
and all that and he said this is a time
that all men I know that pedophile Lou
Pearlman Florida
no it's Anders [ __ ] I don't know he says
Swedish he wrote I want it that way and
all that stuff okay and and he said that
this is the time probably that you won't
see any genius because the turnaround is
so quick that nobody's getting and ha I
beg to differ just Carlson that's him
and and I beg to differ I think post
Malone is a smooth up genius
okay well that's people around I don't
think
genius by the penis he is very town
musically they say especially people in
the business like ups fast as he can
write a song yeah and helped help these
on the keep it might be really good and
fast oh but I don't know that those I
don't know if those songs are gonna
laugh it's what all old people say you
know I'm saying the video this is what I
love about like you'll understand this
because you've been in the business for
a long time like Ed Sheeran's a guy that
[ __ ] everybody off who just goes well
yeah man just got to be hot it's got to
be hot you'll succeed
yeah and then you see that bridge troll
selling out arenas and oh nothing Matt
nothing means anything everything's
chaos I don't even know why
well good he's legit he's good but it's
like it would make you feel better if
you look like Shawn Mendes so you could
go well of course yeah but you look at
this guy you like oh I guess anyone can
succeed literally anyone I mean he looks
like a make-a-wish kid who didn't die
and just grew out the hair and your eyes
are crazy oh he's great most successful
tour of all time better than YouTube by
40 million you too James I just take
your fascism so good at thank you that's
impressive
now I mean is there a sir every which
way but it was Game of Thrones right and
yes so much hate for it it was weird
media now but by the way that's the only
thing it makes sense --'tis in its Game
of Thrones he's kept pigs more sexy and
18-month hiatus makes a lot more sense
to me that you've been on arena 300 days
Hammond he's taking an 18-month hiatus
well its use on the road for like three
hours just got married any as they say
he's gonna be a billionaire from all
this touring so he's like oh I'm good
I'm gonna write some more songs I'll be
back there for hammer look at that - two
dudes
that's a lady oh boy whatever listen
she's safe though whatever they say it
is in Westeros Westeros did you watch
the yeah you a fan of the IOT you know I
did I was a fan of it in the way that 34
year old should be a fan of things right
so on and what that was good yeah moved
on and then I'm out immediately yeah it
moved on immediately didn't care about
the last season didn't care that it
wasn't exactly what I wanted want to
assert you win I liked Cersei yeah but
nobody else did everybody else
oh she's evil blah blah he [ __ ] her
brother I had no problem they knew that
I didn't win but I was like okay I moved
on
yeah I just thought when the dragon
destroyed [ __ ] everything yeah I was
like well you lost your mind you're
[ __ ] an [ __ ] yeah but I like the
way that the the mother dragons Danny
the way she turned because I think
that's every whoa person is that
everybody wants everyone everything down
yes every politically well person just
wants enough power can destroy the city
so they can be the queen I agree
absolutely why could a great drop
because they want to be Trump yeah
that's it I think I thought it was funny
how everyone would they said the cast
when they were reading through the the
script on the last day how people had to
get up and walk out they're furious and
some were crying yeah it was clear I'm
making a million in episode they were
furious it would've been like hey shut
up wait wait wait wait hey cattle bags
this is beautiful this is amazing love
this hold on so I can get more hatred in
my heart
wait I said there a ring through it and
mine is to the actress Meryl I believe
and wear costumes that don't matter they
rain through they're doing the table
reading they said like a few more like
them crying wait and but he's probably
laughing no no no no they're not up
there because the show is over or what
no that is characters [ __ ] you know
if they've been together forever and
then they were just you know reading
through it
oh they got emotional I thought they
were mad at the ending like they were no
somewhere somewhere there might be like
that we were furious my character she
went out like that okay but shut the
[ __ ] it's like hey remember when you
were a waiter yeah remember people do
Starbucks
yeah you're [ __ ] flying on drag
thanks to would yell at you didn't bring
their ranch dressing and now you're
making a million dollars a week it's a
lot of money yeah save that money a lot
of your not gonna work again um I love
the way you said that I live yeah that's
a lot of you a lot of you you've reached
the end of the line that's what that's
52 anybody in the business a long time
yeah you just see how these stories play
out but a lot of them get like that nice
another shady dragon do anything else
besides [ __ ] fight people and
medieval thing I don't want to see him
is like no choices he makes now are
gonna be no I don't like the buddy cop
movie all right well they'll try to push
him into something big he's got he's got
something special but my guess is
they're gonna go you're gonna do these
six action movies we're gonna make
another chick on the left is Jean Grey
the one who's married to the Jonas
Brothers she Jean Grey in the new x-men
so she's thriving he actually just got
signed on to the new Marvel film
eternals I know of course it's not
consigned tomorrow but he's got a heroic
quality to him there's something really
yeah you you believe in him yeah yeah
I've set the eyes I guess he's not a
tall guy if I've said no aren't most
actors like 510 you know five six though
plus yes but they're all like 510
everybody from James Caan did you name
it yeah they're all like 510 I mean
Martin Sheen everybody you can think of
De Niro I saw Jack Efron once you're
like small he's like I mean yeah yeah he
is exact that like a small purse a small
dude yeah but it when you as a kid if
you're they're that young and your kids
are getting to show business you're not
gonna be a big hulking dude I was an act
as when I was next when I was 12
really that was at Sesame Street a few
times yeah damn you've heard of it I
didn't know son man Joey kids all over
the world believe in it I was on it
twice I made about two hundred and sixty
dollars you're good yeah characters like
Elmo or cookie that I saw that big meth
head who plays Big Bird Carol whatever
his name is
oh yeah and then I met and then I did
the polka was snuffleupagus it
snuffleupagus yeah that's on YouTube
it's please bring the action polka with
snuffleupagus this is a very embarrassed
God Big Bird actor retires him for
nearly 50 years dude make it well I
don't think Tim
we'll come up I think it spoke it was
snuffleupagus although maybe it where it
is let me see it's just gotta be polka
with snuffleupagus but I just danced
with ya there it's the third one down oh
no this is not it's the second well I'm
sorry this is all now he has to wear
that outfit yeah honey inside of it he's
in sweating his ass up
is this right I wonder I don't I might
kill myself is that that you run the
back there I don't know but it's the
putt it is on there today it's pokey
like I danced a polka with them how much
money did be how much were they getting
public job you don't get any money you
get no money nobody gets any money why
they're begging for my birthday hey
they'll get paid yeah they're you're
here it is there I am right there where
are you the blonde with 45 year old with
the blonde hair
the kid who obviously shouldn't be there
oh my god whoa cut dude yeah dude that's
that Long Island bull yes right so I get
it I think you're gonna be like are
above yeah I was Brendan thanks for
bringing it up I did think no I believe
everything you're doing right now and I
know the difference yeah everything
you're doing they've seen deal he's not
as mark I know what I'm doing look at
your hands by the way put your hands
closer to your penis
there and there cool cool is he I'm sure
for you as a kid your um yeah a few kids
thought it was cool um did you go back
to school the next day think you're a
big dick Harry um I think it was it was
cool but it wasn't like yeah me and this
this chick god only knows what happened
to her huh that's the girl from the
others probably had a very Billy eyes
yeah now they didn't have me do any
speaking roles cuz my voice was
literally the same as it was now it was
nothing fun about that I think
fundamentally a little kid you know is
natural blonde dude good good you're
Irish Irish am Irish so I mean listen so
then you got Shawn you got out of the
game I got 12 or 13 why because there's
no real roles if you are going through
puberty and look like you're going
through puberty
yes so a lot of the young kids are
played by older people or they are but
you know how it is so like and listen I
tried for like six years and got nothing
I started with our six first play it was
six
I toured around the country with a
Broadway show for two at Holiday my mom
yeah I tried you know no one on a bunch
of auditions try that for like grace
under fire which was like Brett Butler's
sitcom I made it to like the third
callback and then they found a kid who
was like shorter than me look better
standing next to her that kid was like
one of the Sprouse brothers she was such
a nightmare on that show yeah oh my god
which is a big polka willing no the
comics your stand-up comic yeah got a
huge show and she became you were I'm
sure you remember so difficult I guess
that she just that was the closest I
ever got was great under fire I got the
second callback third callback I was
gonna go to screen test in LA and my mom
and dad were like oh we're gonna get
where we're gonna be rich because they
think they're gonna be rich too he's
still like oh we're gonna we're gonna
take your money Macaulay Culkin's oh
yeah we're gonna go and live in LA we
can ditch Long Island yeah you know we
can Chuck Lorre
yeah it did she was such an item heiress
and then and Holly was like I have no
idea let's see the kid look how close am
I to that kid very much you know what I
mean no I I almost got it bro the kids
pretty cute
you know what Brendan didn't see the
ability to you didn't see what I could
do you're right can you tell me what I
could do you're just judging it I'm not
and I think you are but see like yeah I
almost got who's on there yeah that kids
Piney I was not doesn't that it's not
what's the name from Fraser that David
hears no that is just even that I don't
know the smooth
Oh show and I've never heard of her I
wonder what everyone's Pat Butler well
you haven't heard of her but she used to
be
she's big she used to be a big deal
really yeah and then she became possible
southern oh the real problem and they
went Hollywood went this way they lost
his money we'll see you later yeah she
passed away no she's probably still
doing stand-up someone's probably
somewhere just you know getting hammered
and yeah saying the n-word I will just
imagine
just guessing that's really having a
great I'll tell you right now some real
fun stuff comes out about Jews after a
few drinks - right yeah nice and I need
her erratic behavior stemming from
substance boat she was dismissed from
the show
hello should go well cancel the series
moved out of Los Angeles onto a farm in
Georgia where she lives with 15 pets
yes and she can say whatever she wants
him counts and they won't talk back and
Brad loves ouch
Wow that's when well this she's happy I
guess hey she was a pretty good you left
why'd you decide to leave New York I was
the most successful person in New York
City and the wealthiest I think that's a
little I don't know if I broke that Wow
there's no Brian no I know
Ince everybody not zomick's out there
man it's not true I was successful I had
surpassed Seinfeld laughs again Louie CK
louis c.k tell if anything I surpassed
polo size Orman I'd surpassed all of
them yeah and I was I was older the
richest person made sense
I made more money than a lot of the
hedge fund guys I don't know how you
made that more than oh no your
negativity is really sees you it doesn't
mean it's you know I'm just you know was
it residuals from it so once I got to
the pinnacle of New York well I
literally own New York society about I
had to get out to come here and then
take it over and I'm halfway there
you are halfway there you've been here
for how long uh three months you came in
like a tidal wave but I becoming a lot
I've been coming out here Elena now
becoming in Enochs I just see me story
yeah I just started
I will I'd start but I started working
there probably three months ago but I
would come in and out and uh I just
wanted to change I was just like I grew
up in New York I've lived in New York
you've been doing the whole circuit with
everybody the whole struggle with New
York I started coming out here i
medicate it was a cool dude we started
making those videos I was like this is
really fun I'm having fun doing this
what were your classes I mean what were
your clubs did you I was gonna stand a
lot is it Gotham caroline's things like
that i cellar never in a de cellar
really yeah I left before I was like in
there a lot of great clubs oh I mean the
guy's a comic strip still a pleasure
ah yeah so around I think cycle there
yeah I mean I don't think I start know
what's going on - Kampai yeah I don't
either
I mean Dangerfield you want to perform
like five people and the waiter is like
84 but that's fun that's fun not really
but that's great it's fun like one time
and then like the second time you're
like well this isn't so you gotta came
out here just cuz you need a change I
needed to change I was also focused see
it like I was I was podcasting a lot and
I wanted to build that night and I those
videos I started to make I started to
enjoy and I was like these are really
funny and I want to do something in you
know with those and you know all the
people that I make them with around here
I just felt like it was time to go time
to move you know make sense it was yeah
bring up some of these videos - it's on
YouTube or your Instagram it's on
Instagram
Tim Dylan related - so I mean it's just
like the we just started to do a lot of
this stuff like I did one where I was
spoke out I was Jeffrey Epstein's prison
guard oh let me see that which miners do
the IG TV you know go to the you YouTube
my play that go to youtube go to youtube
you play through didn't you go to
epsilon only the video I've had enough
he's in front of his house yeah I
dressed up as a I did a sting operation
and I don't believe Jeffrey Epstein is
guilty because I did a sting operation
where the biggest the first videos
well that's Burning Man that's a guy
that that's a that's a guy that went to
Burning Man but uh yeah the Epstein
prison guards all the way to the right
and then we you could look at the one
from his hospice is although it's like
this is a guy Saul who comes up with
these who writes him you I write him and
then my buddy helps me at at them cuz
sometimes I don't know what is funny
Tommy Delvecchio DiBenedetto and I was
Jerry Epstein security guard at the
Metropolitan Detention Center a lot of
people on online are trying to pin this
on the [ __ ] Clintons let me tell you
man they're good [ __ ] people they
love this they visited him three times
this week in the middle of the [ __ ]
night because they didn't want to make a
big deal out of it cuz the [ __ ]
humble you should have seen Hillary
Clinton when she saw him it was like a
[ __ ] dog that just you know when
their owners in Iraq and he comes back
she just [ __ ] lunge
[ __ ] pull her off and she was so
[ __ ] excited they [ __ ] loves each
other sometimes goes what happened to
those suicide watch people commit
suicide that's why we pray it looked
like they were drinking like why is some
dark red liquid in a chalice the Bahamas
my friend said he had underage girls in
there I said you know my cousin had that
[ __ ] problem but you know what he did
he found a girl that looked young but
was really all this [ __ ] you know those
girls that like look for team but
they're 40 you know you don't [ __ ] it
with your down on your I [ __ ] love
you you saved that man's life I mean
that's like definitely a guy that
allowed that to happen there's got to be
a prison guard even if it is I think
there is some going on there was like
foul play there's gotta be some idiot
that they were like oh we could
literally and it's definitely like a guy
I grew up with we could easily distract
this guy by saying we have a better
parking spot while we go and kill them
yeah if you go to the Instagram that's
the one where I did it in front of his
house we go back to the Instagram I said
to my friend I said why don't we go to
Jeffrey Epstein's mansion in New York
and then I'll dress up like a schoolgirl
and we'll do a sting up or you could go
down a bit was there any problem did you
have any problems no because New York is
basically like you can kind of just walk
up to anybody's house and kind of do
anything you want I mean that's a great
thing but there it is right right yeah
there it is you're a football fan a
little bit yeah
this is all part of the sting operation
islands in play and getting murdered if
I opened my mouth I don't mind that I
think it's fair what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ]
listen if there were real pedophiles in
there they would be [ __ ] deep in me
to retreat of time
the whole thing's [ __ ] hello every
dentist you've ever had his name Jeffrey
Epstein let's be on so got an innocent
dentist who's in [ __ ] jail everybody
thinks he's running some [ __ ] child
trafficking network well here's the
child waiting to be tried
[Music]
did you get [ __ ] from the New York is
there now ah no one cares what's New
York you'd knowing here is like where is
that where is his mansion it's on the
Upper East Side of Manhattan it's
beautiful I mean it's seventy five
million dollar mansion you know I think
it's I think it's about forty thousand
square feet I think it's the largest
private residence in New Yorker it's
50,000 square feet
whoa it's massive what was he working
for a farm I mean that's why he had the
manager wife throw it all away what the
human trafficking I know that's where I
forget it we can enhance yeah they kind
of yeah
they made all the bank he's up but those
videos are fun and I we just started
making them in LA in there we just want
to we want to keep pushing the
boundaries of what we can get away with
I think it's great I think it's fun
not as funny so we just try to be funny
man keep doing things like that oh
that's the only part of it too that 75
million dollars just that building Oh
buddy
well dude yeah buddy maybe even more
there's my matches in your 420 sets 56
million dollars 56 yeah I mean this is a
block from Central Park it's a beautiful
private residence and in New York it's a
private giving him black stones Victoria
yeah for V who owns Victoria's Secret
that's why I think there's that I think
that he was working for a foreign
government
Wow what about our own government I
don't know I think maybe the Israelis
you think the Mossad you don't think but
I think that there he was running a
Mossad he he I don't believe in I'm not
a big conspiracy theory guy so I just
think it's really hard for people to get
away with it it's hard for people to be
in this organized spot sure but I do
think that foreign governments engaged
in this stuff so we're not American
here's an idea
well they do but here's my it would it
be possible would it be advantageous and
in the interest of a government let's
say the Israeli government to have
really successful and influential
politicians and business leaders in
compromising positions why we all CIA
want that too why wouldn't a special
intelligence a because there are because
you'd have to you'd have to pass that
through the Senate Intelligence
Committee just a bunch of oh no firewall
do you believe that well that you really
believe the CIA Starnet pass everything
do to sound intelligent
CIA you to get funding for anything I
mean there's a lot of their civilian
oversight there's a lot of there's a lot
of things a CIA it's not as bad I'm
still gonna have to go through all kinds
of legal hurdles the problem is nobody
wants an wartime things happen but the
idea that you have this really elaborate
not only how long not only the company I
agree it's the Mossad
it's those foreign governments they're
bad what the CIA they're bad people
there's nothing the CIA wouldn't engage
in some kind of blackmail do the exact
same thing they would they would David
the CIA has spied on the Senate and
destroyed tapes of them torturing people
they've spied on elected representatives
so I mean listen man I don't know but I
wouldn't just say foreign and also the
idea that this guy's an American citizen
and the CIA wouldn't have any clue about
this guy's on reddit knew about it yeah
guys on reddit in a basement right what
value would know about it yeah I think
the CIA might have had a little idea
yeah who knows did you see the painting
he had in Berlin
yeah a dress that was no Bill Clinton in
a dress like sipping [ __ ] like this
giant pink this is where all these
people get so heated with these
conspiracies yeah Clinton's drinking
blood and kill I mean it gets a little
far-fetched you look I don't think the
guy don't put a lot past the clouds the
giant painting I love the idea of the
rock that's wow I went to the the comics
were you with me chin what did you go to
in DC when I went to the comic pizza
ping-pong around I saw a photo of it I
went there put that photo of it yes if I
was in the conspiracy there is that's
that I mean this is basically what I
think it is is like Clinton like look
like this guy is my [ __ ] type of thing
or yeah I own him I only has that that
that's that's what it looks like right
it looks like funny but it looks like
Clinton owns you there but he's an
address I mean I think it I love the
idea Bill and Hillary the morning after
Epstein was killed just kind of making
pancakes
you know the radios on there kind of
dancing around the kitchen it's just I
love the idea of them killer I could
never picture them having sex back at
picture them who ordering a man stabbed
a hundred percent and that to me is love
that's me the thing is that cleanse the
cleanse have a lot of enemies especially
in the current government so the problem
with all that is that wouldn't be nice
not exactly you know the Clintons are
involved in involved whitewater Mew can
look at it this is where all of these
families are all involved in something
there's a cropper the paper trail of
corruption the Clintons were very
foundation you had you had buying
influence with a secretary of state it's
crazy look at the Clinton the Clinton
[ __ ] it was paper black it was a it was
a slush fund yes much fun it was a
hundred cents less so were you you you
basically gave money and you got trouble
Trump is very shape grab my shoes
sandals well these are my break
these are my Tevas dude tegus this isn't
the real I thought the teams were the
ones with a strap around that yeah they
are those are divas bro no these are my
like these are my athletic the I feel
like these are these are my surfaces for
surfing let's do some current events I'm
not mad you sure chin thanks man
Portland yeah we're just in Portland
right what do you think it's one of my
favorite yeah fun spot are you going up
there I'm not going up there recently
I'd be soon but a little in a little
while were you were you going through I
don't know probably helium helium in
Portland yeah yeah Club yeah oh you're
on the road soon or no yeah I'm on the
road were my I'm stress factory in New
Jersey
September 5th to the 7th and I'm at go
bananas next weekend Cincinnati the
weekend after stress factory I'm all
over like two week two to three weekends
a month yes for study I'm auditioning
for some stuff I'm kind of a specific
type what do you mean yeah if you by
that you mean cute yeah well the my
voice I'm not it's a regional do the
super injury you gotta want an East
Coast dude yeah you got like a lot of
them dude I don't want a guy that works
on a ferry yeah you gotta want a dock
worker yeah could you drop some worker
construction worker you gotta want to
gotta say some real racist [ __ ] you put
the voice like this I can't say anything
like progressive like I gotta say stick
with your own yeah I gotta say the
neighborhood is changing get out of here
yeah get out of it off my lawn get off
my lawn stuff like that don't touch the
car you want to race I like a guy all I
know is the white man yeah right this is
a white country you know like that type
of good luck Sam what do you got chin oh
hey be some
there's stuff that interferes are there
happiness or prevent you from achieving
your goals sometimes you gotta get out
of your own way man sometimes with the
Oscars bro you gotta talk to somebody
yeah doc somebody a little smarter than
your buddy at the gym maybe somebody who
has a trained professional
dude I'm talking about better help and
you can access your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist right now you can start
communicating in under 24 hours it's not
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online you can give you a perspective
I've been the therapy thinking I knew
everything I walk in this is a
professional and I got a lot out of it
and you can too with the most successful
people I know usually five hundred
thousand people have already been
customers have better help and they've
taken charge of their mental health with
the health of an experienced
professional fighter and kid listeners
get 10% off the first month at better
help.com slash fighter that's better
help.com slash fighter give it a shot
it's important hey be you've been hiking
you work out right you ever get done
working like kind of well how many
calories that burn yeah
what hike for 90 minutes today I posted
on my Instagram story I burned 1200 Cal
how do you know that how do you know
that you put I know 1,200 what's that
say no more bro that's the whoop that's
the way whoops we won out there it is
whoop 3.0 strapped it connects to my
phone it tracks everything from my
workout output heartrate my heart rate
my sleep cover if I'm recovery strength
yeah to a tee there's no more guessing
for me right there's no more guessing
live your heavy engages like each stage
of sleep your RAM your deep your light
sleep everything man recovery strained
sleep all of it it provides insights
through an app and it gets all of your
heartrate
everything it's tracking your heart rate
a hundred times per second times per
second yeah it has a little thing
exactly when I'm working out how how
fast my heart's going
I wore my freakin hot freakin spin class
the other day right and also he doesn't
give you you know since you're my friend
I'll do it the hot spring class he goes
dude I burned 15 our cars when I do this
for an hour
look my favorite we burn 900 bro yeah I
love bringing people down this yeah it
all has a strange is I it it gives you a
training level recommendations based on
your body's recovery to take the
guesswork out of how to push yourself
for optimal training so it'll tell you
exactly where you should be it's it's
amazing man and it uh it's so easy the
the battery usually lasts about five
days mine's a little longer
super easy to charge you can wear the
battery on there just take it off and
you can use to analyze your performance
or share with a coach yeah man I've been
posting on social media try and keep up
bros loop has provided you guys $30 off
your first purchase with the code
fighter just go to woop woop comm that's
wh ooo p calm use the code fighter at
checkout save $30 off and optimize the
way you train no more guessing again
that's woop calm promo code is fighter
save $30 off whoop there it is so just
an update Popeyes has announced that
they are set to sell out of all of their
triple sandwiches by the end of this
week this is a marketing have you ever
had one Tim I've not had one do my
attitude about that everyone's like
Popeyes your chick-fil-a it's like
listen whatever sandwich you know you
eat while the state takes your kids away
it's fine you know because the people
that eat those two things are usually on
their way to Family Court so whatever
you happen to sustain yourself with
while waiting for your lawyer to show up
it's fine it'll be fine you're gonna be
you're probably got bigger issues yeah
anyone's standing on a line I know his
cliff did it no of Tony but as a person
who is eating the wrong things and a lot
of them to stand on a line no never
well this is [ __ ] anyway this is if
you don't run out of snow you'll run out
yeah that's just what's like chick-fil-a
is that you know and [ __ ] saw Marty he
said he did like his bruises he just
brought out a good one cuz I first but
there were no this is all Morris it's
like the easiest thing it's like
increase the demand get everyone talking
cuz chick-fil-a then I open on Sundays
for a reason I ain't in for it six out
of seven days yeah the record
oh I do think just to go back yeah I do
think there might be some conspiracy
involved with the Epstein case I don't
think the dessous is I don't think that
he was killed I don't know how you get
into that Dad that part I have maybe he
was allowed to be himself yeah
that may be but I do believe I do
believe that the phenomenon of Jefferson
Jeffrey Epstein is very possibly a
construct and was constructed by a
certain government or something there's
no state whether he worked for the CIA
or the Mossad right now wherever
wouldn't be a little bit of all yeah
right I agree and and all the above and
that the CIA or so or our intelligence
community at least knew yeah what he
might do I'm very glad to live in a town
that respects and takes care of children
Hollywood yes just my prayer to be here
no one does it better when does it
better man think we need have been at if
you moved here when you're a kid I would
it was called successful that's right
would've been okay
Shia LaBeouf I would have been just you
know what those Steven Spielberg parties
just I was hot at eight that's a reality
I was very hot at a just hotter day
peaked at eight peak today what else you
got chin so in more Fried Chicken News
KFC is actually teaming up with beyond
meat which is the brand making
plant-based meat patties and now they're
gonna have fake giant and I haven't
tried am i fine so disgusting dog take a
look at what the end that it's dog food
out of it it's like soybeans i legit but
then they they put the fake blood to
it's like ah that's what I mean it's
beet juice
not only that they take they say that
meat like hamburger smells like an old
person so they had that old person smell
in there I'm serious that's the smell oh
yeah well it was so disgusting like look
at how many ingredients are in a beyond
burger with the hard path for me dude a
hard yeah that's not going alright go
[ __ ] yourself
no is it beyond me no it's not yeah is
it I'm sure
water be precise what expeller press
canola oil just eat beef refried yoga
now rice protein and other natural
flavors it's not that no there's there's
other stuff before they test it in labs
and they made certain smells they what
ingredient smells it's more nut though
sorry there's a ton of bad food in there
well that looks delicious
to me you see to me if you're vegetarian
a lot of that vegans but it's yeah
because we in like [ __ ] hummus and
cheese all money for carbs your head
it's like yeah that is this fattening
there's a lot of [ __ ] in there is bad
stuff there's a lot of tried I don't
even know it is Dom Arabic what does
gums are all made in the [ __ ] it's
all made in a lab it's not yeah say what
you want but it's not real juice extract
for colour you haven't make your like
bloody Oh what they need what they need
is when they when they come up with meat
that's made in a lab without a nerve
central nervous system so it's doing
that suffering free meat
that's 7,000 dollars per pair yeah
pretty soon it'll be cheap yeah wild but
I love all these people that are looking
at KFC this is sweet healthy like I love
people they're like hey I'm not gonna
stop eating KFC but I want to be
responsible I need some options look at
how sweet this is this little boy was
crying he's autistic oh I hold his hand
so this photo went viral when the mother
of the child Christian which is the
little black boy she posted this on to
her Facebook and it went viral because
the little boy saw the other oh just cry
it's the Hat they just keep trying enjoy
a nice knowing exactly everything is ads
there is a little boy crying in the
corner nervous about his first day of
school another child went to control him
held his hand and walked him to his
class they're now friends and this photo
went viral the mom of the little boy who
was crying saw this go viral and said
thank you so much for your son helping
my son out he's actually autistic and he
was really nervous about his first day
of school maybe three days Akito but I
think that's [ __ ]
I would not put that online that keeps
you to punch the other kid I don't know
is this the key dude I mean do you think
he should have been like sack up yeah
dude I mean Kasich just [ __ ] together
bribe and sock to me I mean you should
have he should you know might be the key
to document I don't know it might be
that key down what a cute little cute
vanity like that yeah I love her the
Internet's just literally a nightmare
and then once a week to like here's a
kid holding another kid's hand I know
here's someone helping a dog across the
street now back to hating each other
there be hate on this the trolls blood
yeah [ __ ] I'm stealing his lunch oh
by the way this this photo and hashtag
[ __ ] is now trending so I don't want
to say we're a horrible country but oh
you are so [ __ ] yeah yeah
so adidas has just signed a deal with
program pro gamer ninja neither can you
element man he's killing it but [ __ ]
this guy whatsapp Rosie Lana you left
twitch throwing up a platform they paid
him how much maybe million 20 million
right now it was a really really big
deal he's a huge deal I don't respect
people that don't use their own name I
mean any extreme winner is probably the
same he'd be as an extreme winner I
watched his documentary on Kelly Slater
[ __ ] samurai I know I'm late to the
party I know how much he's won but
Achilles later but he's such a freak
like he's such a freak he's so good what
yeah I mean it's a Kelly Slater dude I
mean been a legend for it no I
understand that what advocating Michael
Jordan what's the same to Michael Jordan
right so you're seeing like ninja we
like you just a killer in any I don't
know these extreme runners who are these
outliers they have something to them
that I'm not a very great surfer I'm
saying there's something about these
guys that makes them that good at a
gamer they have a different outlet they
can see things very easy is incredibly
explainer has big apparently really big
feet he's double-jointed he's got a
weird body right everything about his
body fits surfing yeah he's so far and
away [ __ ] great yeah
but yeah he is the first professional
gamer to get a deal with a shoe company
he will get six to eight million a year
about twenty four million twenty for a
million for three years
ah did you see momentum generation know
about about Kelly Slater in the group
was famous surfer Hamilton but I mean it
all came up house and they all came from
broken homes last year yes last year and
it's it's so worth watching because I'll
watch what can i want to HBO this [ __ ]
that these guys would do in how they
came up together and when you're serving
there the guy goes well you you can be
the king of your Beach if you can't surf
Hawaii you ain't [ __ ] Wow and not only
in Hawaii when you go there the locals
will beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you if
you're not a killer said Jim it so now
Hawaii's where you get those crazy waves
right oh dude yeah sure and they die how
about that people get break their net oh
my god you get slammed into the coral
it's a great time well it well good
because I think there should be a little
risk well oh sorry honest this is a
great [ __ ] documentary I'm gonna
check that out yeah he's a slave hard
man
but I mean I always knew that Slater was
now a liar but then the way they break
this down on how strategic are now
competitive and and how he just kept
winning it's just it's I'll always watch
if surfing's on it like a bar I'll
always watch if I'm eating or something
me too all what's always watch surface
is fascinating to watch yeah I love
watching it I love the guys on the wave
runners that are like a high on the wave
them as the guys wild right crazy it's
an interesting thing that I don't know
enough about and I'd like to watch a
documentary and learn about it and
forget everything I learned extreme I
hate when I watch you diagnose I can't
remember any of it it's Eddie Murphy's
returning to us and all the hosts after
35 years Wow yeah you know December
you're gonna let me tell you right now
it's gonna be it's a different world you
can't be dropping that bomb he's coming
back to a different climate you know see
ya I'm interested with that because if
you watch Eddie stand up right he
dropped a lot of he said [ __ ] that's a
lot yeah a time oh yeah
very well yeah right you know there so
that's yeah however there's rumors that
he swings that way so if the it's not
just rumors he's been arrested never
tell even knew you never it's dark it's
like well you might judge the man right
but the thing is is this you just swing
that way so I'm curious if all the the
haters come out and they start bringing
up old tweets like they did of [ __ ]
well he wasn't to ever but they're gonna
say oh look at his materials drop my
driving pocket was the sky what if he
comes out to excuse me dude yeah [ __ ]
I'm more worried that he's not funny
then he'll be hateful like I'm actually
he's too smart for that like you turd
and it's too smart for it right I'm
gonna come back and ruin it he's one of
the greatest performers to have ever
ever ever comics I'm excited to see
whatever he does you know nothing to be
sad if he came back in just eight days
well he knows he knows he was talking
about how Stanek doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you you've got to get back on the
road do you hit on the community cars
getting coffee he talked about he's like
oh no I'm gonna start doing clubs I'm a
staff there he goes you can't take a
long time off and jump back yeah no you
gotta you gotta watch Tripel special
it's brilliant
amazing amazing I didn't watch it on the
paint that's living comic right now I
think oh hey I'm me hands down this and
top three of all top three yes the one
with him and in the jumper yeah yeah
when did it when did it two days a few
days ago great you don't if you keep
watch it it stops and there's a Q&A a
secret key idea interesting it's cool he
was getting he's getting [ __ ] for going
we've gone being misogynistic and no I
mean just on this toilet rolls like it's
like II repeat it's like not even how
about Weis goes don't watch you're
special like you [ __ ] if I said that you
know everybody's can watch a special no
vice by the way is looking to get
acquired like they're waiting to get
bought yeah nobody has bought them so I
think all the me to movements [ __ ] yeah
the title of their thing was like hey
pass on Chappelle specials like yeah
that's what every media conglomerate is
doing to you right now everything so
everyone's been like we're go for
yourself an advising Jeff like skip Dave
Chappelle's new net for special Wow
stick yeah pounds it's so good he owes
he addresses everything goes so hard in
the pink I feel like if you don't like
that
you don't like comedy really if you
don't like the new Chapelle special then
just stand-up comedy maybe not your it's
so dad yeah I think it's his best one
mine will be better I will say that and
then Williams Qing yuan Jun and I that
could be the Kido talking because it's
filled me with a an unhealthy confidence
by inquiry to be out of the week yeah I
think I'll be better than him in like
three days
that makes it five who knows yeah he
goes hard in the paint though man it's
brilliant another one yep it's great all
right this is a pretty bad one this
music where do I belong I look so pale
watches I can oh I just seems because
she says that's his best friend I'll
show you the friendship I don't know he
laughed along with it she was it kind of
looks like you roll down this is our
apology and this is also interesting
because we get here Meisel it's fine
watch Harris she's embarrassed everybody
which is not racist no she's not right
him and that grill have the same eyes
yeah he does a puckered that's not a
racist thing that there's a similarity
in the eyes I'll see the skin colors
what makes it racist but kyanjin we're
all great or no yeah here's the apology
and then watch he there's something else
to look out for she start crying
[Laughter]
it's so it's so I'm super fringy it so
[Applause]
he's like also I'm wide engaged this
isn't a huge issue why she should be
fine what too much where did you out of
control it's a whole thing but if she
goes changing demographics like he goes
changing demographics in she goes we
shut up you gorilla you shut up bird the
demographics you that would be funny
it'd be funny they can't be I mean the
whole thing is like Oh an apology
she was just crying but also started
getting super raises she's like I love
them he's my best friend but we're
different people are different that's
all oh I know listen man people are
people are really on edge in 2010
gorilla Blatt died she's like the
similarity the I it was just a crazy
talking your friend you might say that
to your friend but then you're on air
and it's just something so two guys you
should know that I know that she's so
comfortable with them well all right
what it is we get him pitch in the whole
[ __ ] he's like the demographics is
changing and I started GoFundMe yeah for
a new gorilla exhibit I want to thank
the Nation of Islam they serve Islam
they're both in a bad situation yeah
it's are better fall they're both in an
awkward embarrassing situation [ __ ] yeah
this [ __ ] world and it's all about
it's it's these people on Twitter who
just have some so much control and if
you've got the one but corporations
[ __ ] listen of course Google and they
listen listen yes and your fire gets
taken down answered you get cancelled
for you ma'am what else you get you one
sad Mme one BJ Penn again and it's
another fight and I've Ellen a street
fight though well actually there's a
video that just came out someone just
texted me but let's check this one out
first this is outside a bar yesterday
people just keep [ __ ] with him or
what
I don't know how could you get yourself
in that much trouble though so he
punched this guy multiple times okay
back of the head don't [ __ ] I don't
have the video ready yet but I heard
though awkward where we just got I heard
that he just got knocked out BJ did yeah
just now
there it is right there in I wonder if
it's the same in on either one
well he's not let's see Hawaii they
fight huh Jesus Christ oh it's the same
fight then has to be the guys all trying
to take him down yeah oh he's just
acting a fool yes hammering what do
people want to fight you a lot cuz
you're a fighter never never Ryan ever
yeah never he's scheduled for a fight to
see yeah right
the one last fight against the Nick the
Kearney Lentz nor the last fight that
Dana wants to give them is that a thing
with people when they see people like
that after like let's find you I imagine
he'll think so it's the energy put out
your flight or not it's so big like yeah
you don't want to fight Brendan you know
yeah yeah he's just putting himself out
but like yeah he's got bars and drinking
and we are right talking [ __ ] to people
and yeah that's getting messy that does
the end well by the way guys you know
that right what happens so I had trauma
it's not good doesn't end well okay what
else we get alright one happy one
another friend that's following the Bert
Kreischer stuff he sent this to me
that's very funny America's Got Talent
he actually hit a lavash got the mercury
Got Talent and hit me up - all right
stand up on America Got Talent
I just came across your videos on
YouTube actually loved it would you
consider yourself Mormons the answer a
comedian how well they have idea who he
is
was the dance with a manner to promote
your tour I am the cat strict form I
just got talent
love to speak you about her showing him
dancing on her Jesus Christ
he said the videos and it's reached like
almost four million right now very smart
he I talked to him yesterday about he
trained for awhile for that of course
the real dancers legit yeah taking his
classes now he's Tom's gonna do one he's
like all you guys should do one like he
did it dude yeah like you go set you up
with my girl make this - he didn't do
yeah I do I look like an [ __ ] I
wanted to do one where it was like the
same exact thing as his but I was tap
dancing that's cause I got to add
another element you'd have to do that
yeah like you'd like something else you
got to do ballet you got to do ballet
and classically trained something it's
good it's gotta be good he has to be
like that's funny if it's good it has to
be good to suck yeah that's what comedy
is now getting good at a dance and so
what do you know that's what you all got
to do we got to do it is what it is
tell your soul what else you got Jim
that's it for currents Oh Tim we did it
basic size thank you for having me I
appreciate it
where can they find your uh Tim Jay
Dylan di ll1 on Instagram same handle on
Twitter you guys want to follow their I
have a podcast
Tim Dylan show on apple pie on YouTube
and all that stuff alright so yeah ma'am
I appreciate I think Skillman brother
has a great thanks guys thank you for
the best this is the fighting kid route